well the United States and South Korea
have conducted their first large-scale
amphibious Landing exercises in five
years the drills are taking place off
the coast of eastern pohang North Korea
accused the U.S and South Korea of
rehearsing an invasion on Tuesday
Pyongyang unveiled what it said were new
and smaller nuclear warheads declaring
it will produce more weapons-grade
nuclear material Robert bright is
following those military exercises for
us from pohang
of all of the joint drills that have
been held over the past few weeks this
amphibious Landing exercise is probably
the most dramatic like the other drills
it has been on hold for the last five
years or so it is also probably one of
the more controversial shows of strength
coming during what is meant to be a
rehearsal by the south to defend itself
from an attack by the north hundreds of
U.S and South Korean Marines storming
the beaches would not seem to be very
defensive but then as the Allies argue
this is them rehearsing for a
counter-offensive making themselves such
a formidable foe that no one would think
about attacking them first this exercise
is designed for the uh the combined
defense of the Korean Peninsula and
that's important to us it's important
for the regional stability through this
exercise we've confirmed the solid
Alliance and the combined defensive
Readiness between South Korean and U.S
Marine Corps with Marine Corps in a
decisive battle posture we will
immediately respond to any provocations
North Korea has been has been protesting
against these
drifting a counter-attack of its own
against the South and its U.S allies the
difference being that in its
counter-refensive it would it says be
using the smaller tactical Nuclear
devices that it says it's now developed
and which it's been showing off in
state-run media the devices being
inspected by leader Kim Jong-un Rob
McBride Al Jazeera pohang South Korea
well let's bring in Malcolm Davis he's a
senior Analyst at the Australian
strategic policy Institute and he also
worked in Australian Navy headquarters
he joins us now from Canberra Malcolm as
we were seeing there it's been really
quite the impressive operation open to
the media too so clearly this is meant
to send a message but who's the audience
well I think the message is to several
different audiences firstly is obviously
to Pyongyang because these exercises are
really about sending a message of
deterrence to North Korea in other words
uh you the United States and South Korea
work together they stand together and
they will defeat any North Korean attack
upon South Korea secondly it does send a
message at a more strategic level uh to
Beijing uh making it clear to China and
the Chinese government that the United
States will not turn its back on as key
allies in the region South Korea Japan
Australia and others and so by
demonstrating this military capability
close in and for all the world to see
there's a strong message of deterrence
and also reassurance Malcolm you heard
our correspondent Rob there saying that
it may look to some like more of an
attack than a defensive move Pyongyang
will no doubt regardless as very
provocative
oh of course they will uh but frankly
they regard everything that the West
does as provocative uh this is not an
attack okay this is a military exercise
uh to practice defending South Korea
against a North Korean attack okay so
there's nothing offensive about this
whatsoever uh this is about defense it's
about deterrence it's about reassurance
of South Korea and also Japan that the
US is standing by its allies and will
work with its allies to ensure stability
and Security in the in the indo-pacific
region against all potential aggressors
Malcolm I believe this is a resumption
of this specific kind of drill after a
halt of quite a few years can you talk
us through the timing here
look the timing I think is significant
um obviously there was a bit of a halt
due to covid uh which I think was quite
understandable they went to a series of
table type exercises for a while to try
and essentially open the door for some
sort of negotiation possibility with the
north to see if the North Koreans would
agree to some sort of denuclearization
it's painfully obvious that the north
has no intention whatsoever of
denuclearizing crap in fact quite the
reverse it's building up its nuclear
capabilities including
developing lots of small tactical
nuclear weapons that are designed for
coercion and use on the battlefield so I
think these exercises have been restored
as a means of deterrence and signaling
to Pyongyang that the US will not be
forced to back down even in the face of
North Korean nuclear threats Malcolm I
know amongst defense analysts has also
been talk of a practical shift in the
U.S approach to North Korea effectively
acknowledging as you suggested there
that it won't give up its nuclear
program is this part of that
look I think that reality has been in
place for some years now I think that
the US government uh goes through the
the sort of the protocol of saying that
North Korea must give up its nuclear
weapons but everyone understands that
North Korea has no intention of giving
up its nuclear weapons so what we have
to do is deter North Korea from using
those nuclear weapons that means
strengthening uh U.S South Korean and
U.S Japanese relations it means
enhancing U.S abilities closer into
North Korea there's been some discussion
in South Korea about how nuclear sharing
might work on the peninsula where the US
might base nuclear weapons on the
peninsula uh the South Korean president
even hinted at the possibility that
South Korea could get nuclear weapons
although he walked that back fairly
quickly but I do think that you know the
alarm is growing that the really North
Korea is building up its nuclear weapons
and not just for deterrence but also for
coercion so we have to respond to that
threat Malcolm we've obviously seen
everyone try to show off their weapons
and their capabilities should we
understand anything special about this
amphibious drill that we've seen today
look I think that these sorts of
capabilities that you're seeing with the
amphibious vehicles coming out of the
onto the beach uh and just discouraging
uh troops out the back they've been
around for many decades so there's
nothing new there but the really
interesting things about military
technology now in terms of amphibious
operations is what's known as
operational maneuver from the sea where
you have hilly-borne and Airborne assets
that can deploy straight from the ship
over the beach straight into the
objective maneuver uh the the to
maneuver close to the Target that's a
new approach to amphibious operations is
very different from what you see for
example in Saving Private Ryan where you
know the Allies land on Normandy Beach
and 44 and have to hold the beach
against withering fire now we simply fly
over the beach and land the objective
and I think that what you're seeing in
action today around the South Korean uh
beaches is that sort of Technology
starting to appear so a real shift in
Warfare Malcolm Davis there senior
Analyst at the Australian strategic
policy Institute thanks so much for
joining us and sharing your expertise on
altazira
thank you very much